To implement this method, we'll use the same kind of
while loop we learned in lesson four. To keep collecting doubles,
as long as the user enters doubles. Inside the loop, we'll
read that double, using the scanner that was passed in. And
then we'll save it. We want to save it in the
next open spot in scores, which should be at index current
size. So we'll put nextscore in there. Now there's a new
element in scores so the size has changed. We'll need to
increment current size to reflect that. let's see it
in action. If I run the demo, and enter some
scores. It saved the scores in the order that I
entered them. Looks like we're ready to add another feature.